today only animes own a review of the
anime movie summer Wars
an anime that explores the endless
possibilities when it comes to our use
of technology I mean think about it
in just a few years time can you imagine
what we can do with the kind of systems
that will be in place welcome to the
world of ours the online platform that
allows you to control your life and
everything around it in this digital
world limitless possibilities are just a
few clicks away at the touch of your
fingertips how may I serve you today
pour pour pour Oh pour and time for anal
sex what's a rim job
I only develop the thing it isn't like I
told you what to do what won't do you
any good
better work for an answer
the advent of social media has become a
huge part of everyone's lives in recent
years and is only growing in influence
you have Facebook the place that proves
that everyone has around 900 friends
that they actually know about 1% of
Twitter the place where you can see when
someone has successfully picked their
nose and would like to tell the whole
world about it
YouTube's proven that television can
successfully become obsolete using a
combination of cats fail videos and
pewdiepie tumblr a place for homoerotic
fan fictions and Doctor Who gifts and
finally reddit and 4chan which I'm
convinced that actually used by some of
the world's most skilled and talented
geniuses in the world who'd much rather
spend their spare time making memes so
what happens if you put all social media
into one place
summer Wars gonna well it's only really
one part of the movie that's just like
shut up this opening paragraph is
totally related to the movie okay in the
near utopian future where the online
world has become this peaceful friendly
place our lives have been integrated
with the world of Oz an online platform
that is essentially an extension of
yourself in the virtual world entire
real world systems are relied on AWS and
pretty much everyone use it so basically
it's an old to advanced happy-go-lucky
version of the internet that rolls cat
videos or porn probably back in a real
world Kenji choicerish your average
teenager who's found himself in an odd
predicament being the runner-up in the
math Olympics he didn't have much
planned this summer but somehow he's
found his way traveling all the way to
the countryside on an odd job set up by
his high-school crush not ski what he
doesn't know is that the job entails a
bit more than he first thought
absolutely not just pretend you're my
boyfriend okay can't do it
Angie will make a wonderful addition to
the family while candy tries his best to
fit in with Nats keys large extended
family things get even worse when he
receives a mysterious and coded text
message which he manages to solve not
knowing that he's accidentally just
released the dangerous virus onto was
known only as Love Machine shut up it's
a threatening name right with Love
Machine wreaking havoc within the world
of Oz the repercussions are slowly being
felt within the real world and as things
get more and more chaotic and the stakes
are raised even higher candy and family
slowly realize that this little computer
virus could pose a bigger threat to the
world than anyone had previously
imagined honey what's happening I mean
this isn't real right
just again isn't it now anime original
movies aren't something I normally do
but at the same time I often overlooked
unless Miyazaki is making his next
blatant message about war in nature or
when its name happens to rhyme with
smash Mira but considering this is
directed by my favorite up-and-coming
director Mamoru soda who did film such
as the girl who left through time and
more recently our main Yuki wolf
children I wanted to shine some light on
him to get the technical aspects out of
the way first well the movie looks great
visually speaking the animation is fluid
and smooth with barely any moments where
anything is just still they managed to
make a stark contrast between the
standard real world setting and the
world of Oz which is a bright and
vibrant place that looks like what would
happen if the internet had sex with
Nintendo except I have no idea what the
[ __ ] this thing is here in the middle
considering it looks like a [ __ ] cat
going through an acid trip on top of
this the soundtrack consists of
orchestral music that feels very
disney-esque in the upbeat and comical
moments but still manages hit home
during the very emotional points and
sounds great the acting and both sub and
dub is also great so uh how can I put
this into a nutshell it's all [ __ ]
great there now with the boring stuff
out of the way let's get into the real
meat of this review the characters and
plot characters were actually the
weakest part since with such an enormous
cast even the main characters which were
basically kenji and uh ski gets very
little development kenji being the usual
shine quirky teenager living his average
high school life of trying to gets
Empire to notice him whose only standout
trait being that he's really really
really good at maths Asians a-and not
ski being the love interest who you know
what has very little relevance to the
story until the final climax then you
have the rest of nuts Keys huge extended
family which probably have enough
members to start a small nation
individually that don't get too much
screen time but special mention goes to
the 90 year old grandma of the family
aka bowls grandma who is the outright
star of this movie as head of the family
she looks over everyone with a kind
heart but also gains respect from all of
them I mean just look at this clip here
and tell me that it doesn't feel like a
gangster interrogation haha this great
granddaughter of mine is no
are you man enough to make my nut ski
happy she about to shoot him oh maybe
[ __ ] well also I'm asking you if you're
man enough yeah oh man this is looking
good for him yeah I guess man enough to
die for her oh [ __ ] he's dead just run
now run while you can when a serious no
though she brings so much heart into
this film and honestly while the
characters may be the weakest part of
the movie but didn't bother me much
I know explain what bits later now it's
hard to talk about the plot of the movie
without spoiling too much but to address
the huge elephant in the room
yes the plot of the movie is essentially
a rehash of the Digimon movie our war
game right down to the art style of the
digital world not that it actually
bothered me much since both were made by
the same director anyway and as much as
I like to Digimon as a kid it's just
[ __ ] Digimon guys and this story was
too great to be contained within that
franchise that's all that so in that
matter because if you have seen a
Digimon movie don't worry cuz some Wars
is done like a 10 jillion times better
yes there is a number I just made up on
the spot and if you haven't seen it then
even [ __ ] better the digital aspect
of the film is an interesting look at
the possible consequences as our lives
get more and more integrated with
technology but it manages to do it
without being too deep and complicated
since this is a family film after all so
they managed to keep things simple
enough for even the kiddies to
understand though the technology in this
film is sometimes simplified to a point
that it makes a very little sense for
example I don't know why this kid is so
good at fighting games just cause he
learned martial arts in real life
because last time I checked practicing
karate does [ __ ] or when you try to
remember a 72 button combination to the
OI gay you can and for the record why is
the computer virus called Love Machine I
mean that name could mean anything from
a really heavy womanizer to the world's
most emotional vibrator but it certainly
doesn't sound like a scary computer
virus that could possibly [ __ ] the
world technological simplifications
aside though the poor's fun and manages
to keep you interested and entertained
throughout so fun in fact that you'll be
chairing a climax based on a card game
that apparently no one actually knows
how to play
will you declare Khoikhoi yeah that's
why you quick way that [ __ ]
I have absolutely no idea what's going
on now I have a confession to make this
is my favorite anime film of all time
and something that I have a ridiculous
amount of personal attachment to but to
properly explain why I've got to go
serious for a second and explain
something about my own morals as a
person rather than being that cheeky
sarcastic [ __ ] on the internet so if the
thought of me be sincere for once
sickens you then I suggest you click off
this video now or just grab a bucket the
technological aspects of the plot really
only take up half the film and the real
reason why this is my favorite anime
film of all time because of the family
which is what gives some awards it's
heart and soul the underlined morals the
film portrays is the concept of family
and how important it is family should be
the people that always have your back
are always there whether you like it or
not and it's not just the family you're
related to you by blood it's the family
you adopt for yourself the family you've
been introduced into and the friends you
choose should introduce it's an
invisible bond that stays with you no
matter how many members are in it and
something you should never turn your
back on some members you make us along
well with some you may not and others
you may not know that well but no matter
what you all share the bond of being in
the same family and it is one thing that
no one should go without this film
portrays that so well and we've such a
large class you could argue that the
characters were the weakest and least
developed parts but that wasn't a point
of it the family itself felt like one
massive character that was reminiscent
of all those family reunions you'd used
to have the Thanksgiving meals and the
Christmas dinners you'd have your
grandparents the drunk uncles the nosy
ants the cousins you do or don't look
forward to hanging out with and the
hyperactive kids every single member
played a part in - given this family's
own character its own heart its own soul
and that's what really makes the
emotional moments hit home as a family
you share each other's sufferings and
each other's happiness and you could
feel the togetherness that everyone held
towards each other which is a concept I
hold very close to myself personally
and that is why this came out to be my
favorite anime film of all time
overall someone was is a bundle of fun
that should not be missed by anyone I'm
not gonna [ __ ] and say that I'm not
slightly biased because of the values
and morals that match up so closely to
my own which makes this my favorite
anime film but even without that it's a
highly entertaining look at how
technology can affect us all along with
a heartfelt story that is friendly for
the entire family it's slightly cheesy
and predictable times but who cares you
should be watching this anyway and
you're damned well walk out with a huge
smile across your face
currently someone was is licensed by
Funimation and unfortunately is not
available for legal streaming but is
available for DVD and blu-ray so get off
your lazy asses and go get it and while
you're there tell them Gygax sent you
hey guys gig okay I hope you enjoyed
that review and I hope you're enjoying
YouTube's geek week at least I hope it's
YouTube's geek week right now otherwise
this is gonna sound very stupid and
random but whatever before we go I've
got one quick announcement to make
I am going to be attending Alcorn in
Leicester from the 5th of September to
the 8th of September so if you've ever
wanted to see me in person and I don't
know maybe hang out or some gay [ __ ]
like that then come hang out of Alken
with me I'll make a prophet announcement
video later but yeah that's it for now
if you need my videos and you can check
some of my other reviews and [ __ ] here
if you like we see why don't just give
me a subscribe stuff I don't know and
don't forget you can follow me on both
Facebook and Twitter in the description
below anyway that's it for now I've been
giggle I hope you've enjoyed my review
and I'll see you all next time